so um the trailer for season five is
totally outrageous it's so much fun it's
been viewed over 13 million times
which is crazy uh so sarah how would you
describe
the shenanigans that rick gets the smith
family into this season
so this season um we get into a lot of
shenanigans and it's kind of fun
it's a season where the whole family
goes on a lot of adventures
together and from an animation
perspective
i think it's like the most beautiful
animation that we've had so far
oh wow i mean you know when you read all
the comments this is the kind of show
that
people just say every season it gets
better and better and people are already
obsessed with that do you agree that
when you're reading the script spencer
oh uh i thought you were still going to
talk to sarah
i was like you guys are engaged in a
lovely conversation
no no i was like oh yeah of course yeah
no i think the scripts do get better and
better
i think that we're tying some loose ends
some things people might have questions
about
and or embracing some alternative
stories that
i think we weren't we
i say we but i mean the writers weren't
necessarily capable of
doing at the time because we had such a
limited amount of episodes that we
didn't know that we have this big
episode order i think
there's so much more room to explore
different things
yeah okay i really want to make sure i'm
doing this right chris just left right
he's gone he's totally gone
he was like how come you didn't ask me
any questions
he's like i don't know why you got to me
third morgan
he was like yeah i can't see him it's so
weird hold on i just want to make
sure nothing's messed up on my envelope
okay
there we go maybe i'm still here
i don't know i don't see any of our
other participants but
yeah he's no longer in the zoom call oh
okay guys let me knock down one second
he said morgan's just being punked we're
all just gonna start
yet he did say to us that we should talk
a lot
and maybe that was just his like secret
way of
slowly being nice
okay simultaneously answering those
questions also
[Laughter]
what if he's answering them and no one
can see
of rick and morty he's just talking to
another morgan in another timeline
oh my god this would be so fitting i'm
kind of jealous of the other morgan now
but that's okay
that's okay that's okay she's only got
him on the call
you know that's right that's all that's
and i got the lightning
[Music]
no no this is this is where i want to be
um do you want me do you want me to just
keep going with the interview or do you
want me to wait
i'm just asking like netflix people i
think we can
um keep sorry this is emily from adult
swim we can keep going for now and then
once chris hops on you can
perfect edit it all together awesome
okay sounds great
um so i watched the first episode so
sarah i have to ask
beth and jerry get a little spicy in the
premiere episode are we going to
continue to see that relationship evolve
we are it's kind of fun how much they've
evolved like since season one
and you know couples counseling off
planet and
one of my favorite things is where you
see how they actually see each other
and she sees jerry is this tiny form um
so
and then obviously you know they
separate and then are back together and
so it's been
so fun to you know explore their journey
over the years and they definitely get
spicy in season five and i'm not allowed
to say anything more
i love that so much so here's the thing
sir you've obviously been on super
popular shows
did you have the feeling even in season
one that this show would stand
out from others like did you know it'd
be a massive success
you know when i i remember reading the
pilot
for the first time and just kind of
being blown away by
the comedy i mean i just the minds of
justin roiland and dan harmon
are stunning and it's been so cool to
get to be a part of them over the past
decade and you know like the second you
get a rick and morty script in your
inbox it's like the most exciting day
and then whatever you imagine in your
mind
can never compare to what you end up
seeing on the screen and kind of you
visualize like
a sentient you know alien cloud fart
being in your head it's never going to
be like what these animators come up
with
and like the wild you know intergalactic
battles and
so i think you know i i definitely
just when i read it thought it was so
cool and so unique and so different and
so groundbreaking
and um i but you never know
you know what's gonna happen with it and
the fact that it's been received
as it has has been yeah so cool watch
yeah okay wait let's check in with chris
chris can you hear me
i can now yes yay fantastic are you in
uh the voiceover books right now
no my booth is behind me here oh nice
sorry that's why i met do you guys now
are you doing uh your voices from home
are you back in studio like how's this
all working
we do it from the studio um yeah we
we've always
at least i've always gone in for rick
and morty into the studio i
um it's it's pretty easy you know you
just put on a mask
you walk into the booth and then take it
off so yeah that's awesome
uh i was just talking to sarah about
beth and jerry this season and how they
get a little spicy
maybe a lot spicy how much fun is it
playing jared this season
it's always fun playing jerry you know
and it's
it's always exciting to see where jerry
goes and where jerry and beth go and
where jerry and rick go i don't have as
much of a relationship with
summer or morty but um
it's good to see you dad of the year
yeah i know i'm sorry
all right spencer takes all this really
personally which i know it's cool
yeah i know it's fine i don't write a
spencer
i don't
[Laughter]
spencer do you ever think summer and
jerry will have a good relationship
if jerry could be more like rick
oh it's all maybe always on me it's
always on me huh yeah
just saying i mean if you every once in
a while like
had an independent thought that wasn't
about yourself then maybe
summer might be like wow that's amazing
wait that's not true though i think
there's some times where
that might be an option
yeah yeah there are
there are some times where that's a
possibility in the future
of episodes possibly i think okay
amazing
amazing because i think allowed to give
no spoiler
it's not i mean
the most vague spoiler ever but i think
you know what's really lovely about this
family is even though it's very
dysfunctional i think everyone's really
rooted in a lot of love
and compassion you know life isn't easy
right
obviously we've watched beth and and
jerry work through a lot of issues in
their relationship
and you know that's kind of what a
relationship is a journey
you know it's true that's so beautiful
thanks yeah i'm currently single but you
know i don't know
everyone else is journeying they're
online journeys
since i feel like summer's always been a
badass but but especially
the past couple of seasons um what do
you love about for this season
in terms of just like owning that
yeah i think this season um summer's
gotten even more confident
and uh as i've i've tried to maybe i've
tried to influence i'm like can she be
more like
rick like can we get more more of an
evil side of summer
um to explore that i also feel like that
in general summer um does skew more to
the
rick side of the family right i think
also she's more like beth and beth is
more like her dad and they're all like
very similar and so obviously rick has
the stronger genes
uh in this family apart from morty
obviously morty got the
jerry jeans but yeah yeah sorry
um
i mean like by the way jerry is quite
possibly my favorite character
so did you know yeah
i didn't know that no i almost said it
changes my relationship with summer's
flash spencer entirely
oh i love that okay it's true i've
identified you
why do you love jerry so much then now i
need
you guys this is such a fun interview so
far um chris i know you've worked on
other animated series we were talking
about like how popular
uh this show is you know sarah kind of
had like an idea about
how great it was season one but why do
you think this show stands out
so much that the fandom is so loyal to
the show
you know it's it's it's i don't think
it's a special
it's not like a secret thing it's just
it's great writing you know
and then then justin you know
uh plays rick and morty so beautifully
uh
you know and is able to improvise as
those characters so well when he wants
to
um and then uh and then you got a you
know a decent cast here with the three
of us and all these great guest stars
um but so much of it is
is the writing i think and then the look
of the show people i think people really
respond to that you know
yeah definitely um so look i love gns
now
i have to ask what was your take on elon
musk and his hosting duties
i've only watched half of the show but
um i thought it humanized him a lot
um i thought he was from what i saw he
was really
trying you know he's really making an
effort i mean i didn't know he was
uh had asperger's i definitely framed
him in a different way and
made him you know more sympathetic i
think because he's not always the most
sympathetic character
um but uh but yeah i was it was
you know it was better than i thought it
would be i thought it seemed like they
were
writing well for what he was able to do
you know
yeah i kind of felt that way too just
reading all the comments um spencer i
want to ask you too
when a frasier revival was announced
people lost it how cool is it that you
get to
see your dad take on that role again
i mean i don't know if he ever stopped
being frasier
in my life but it's definitely exciting
i mean i
i grew up on that set my dad has played
my dad played that character my entire
life
um going from cheers to frasier and so i
grew up watching
the show and i went to tapings a lot
when i was in high school um
mostly i probably to learn comic timing
and i learned a lot from him and from
the other cast and
i'm you know i've been able to work with
perry gilben on another show before
and a lot of the people that he worked
with as a crew on other television shows
and
so it's been lovely to i know how
wonderful it is to work on a set with
him so i know people are really looking
forward to it
um and it's such a great i mean though
that period of time and comedy
there's not like will and grace did a
revival as well and that was such an
amazing revival i was able to go watch
that a bit because i know
i'm jimmy burrows and then obviously
because my dad knows him too
um but i i'm excited because they've all
grown so much as
as actors as people as human beings i
think it'll be really lovely to
fall back into that frasier world of
those crazy
um comedic high
high comedy dinner parties of craziness
i love it it's the best it really is
it's like these silly
over-the-top things that work because
they're such
amazing actors truly yeah and honestly i
think people need that kind of comedy in
their lives more now than ever
so i'm very excited for that yeah yeah
okay so i have one minute left this is
always such a hard question to ask
everyone but i always love everyone's
answers
sarah if you had to describe season 5 of
rick and morty one word what would it be
oh um
i mean top secret is the first thing
that comes to mind
it must be difficult doing preston you
can't say anything
but also because we're recording so we
just finished
um recording six they're writing
devin and beyond um we you know recorded
five
a long time ago so you're always trying
to be like what can i talk about again
what am i gonna talk about um but
um yeah it's it's uh
it gets deep oh i love that so much
that's a great answer
guys thank you so much it was really fun
getting to talk to you
um the comments for the show alone
people are just they can't wait for
season five so it's so exciting to be on
such a great show
congrats guys yeah thank you so much